this has to do with the fact that all of  you hate ads people hate commercials  commercials need to Die the reason I'm  making this video is a lot of you are  creative a lot of you are potential  creators or Ambitions to be a creator  vaynermedia has disrupted the  advertising industry and has built a 300  million dollar a year top line revenue  business by winning in Social creative  and now we're affecting commercials  because we're making videos that are  non-commercial branded videos videos  you'd actually like to watch many of you  should follow that many of you will use  this specific video to start your agency  and build a business for you and your  family and it's all because of this  headline the reality is people just  don't want ads they would rather pay  more not to get them that's how bad they  are but it doesn't have to be that way  ads could actually be epic if you made  videos that people actually wanted to  watch Madison Avenue doesn't understand  that